they're big they're ugly and they're
coming to get us it's the invasion of
the monster king crab
king crab is the largest crustacean in
the world
and they're heading for britain
noi has a massive problem with these
huge giant king crabs they're just
breeding and breeding and breeding
reducing the fish stocks and causing a
huge problem
all the king crab that come to england
are frozen so i'm now going to catch one
kill one and see what it actually tastes
like fresh
from the sea
[Music]
two flights and eight hours later i
landed kirk and s where i met my local
crab hunter lars peter oy welcome to
northern oil thank you very happy to be
here never been this far up it's [ __ ]
freezing here
there's only one way to get around in
norwegian lapland and it's not by car
we're heading over the mountains and
down to the frozen fjord which is where
the crabs hang out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
excellent
unbelievable you get like a child again
you know yeah that was extraordinary
hello good to see you
fifty thousand crabs live under this ice
and if you want to catch one we're gonna
have to dive down beneath it
did you ever try ice diving i've never
been nice diving i've done lots of
diving but
it's a special kind of diving and you
need the special skills but uh
we will try now don't make the hole too
small i want to get out easy just in
case those [ __ ] things are huge
will we stay completely dry
hopefully yeah
so i've never dived in a dry suit before
there's not any water getting there
you feel like a big [ __ ] condom at
least you're very sick
that was hard work though yeah
right
ice diving can be extremely dangerous as
it's so easy to get disorientated in the
freezing dark water
i'm [ __ ] myself
when you fetch a crab you should just
grab one of the legs the claws are very
strong so they can snap your finger and
even uh yeah more so if i'm swimming
over one yeah watch out for my widget
yeah it's gonna be cold down there it'll
be frozen i don't want it snapped off
okay
[ __ ] me it's freezing oh [ __ ]
we could get hypothermia if we stay down
too long so we've got to be quick but
that's easier said than done i can see
the crabs but i can't see the surface
[Music]
[Music]
these freakish beasts grow up to six
foot wide and have no natural predators
so it's down to us to bring their
invasion under control
[Music]
[Music]
good
[Music]
go
oh
god almighty
a lot harder than i thought it would be
yeah the size of the thing good sighting
and look at her
beautiful
my balls feel like two big [ __ ] ice
cubes
[Music]
lars has shown me how to catch a giant
crab now i'm going to show him a new way
to eat it
but first i've got to kill it okay
yep
yeah
then it's dead actually now it's
bleeding out yep yep
we cut off the legs and boil them in
seawater for 15 minutes discarding the
body which isn't that good to eat
because the quality of the king crab is
so delicious it doesn't
need
much more no yeah so i'm just gonna do
something very very simple with the
creme fresh mayonnaise and some tarragon
yeah and some lime okay
i'm making the sauce by mixing equal
amounts of mayonnaise and creme fraiche
with some lime zest
salt and pepper
roughly chopped tarragon and freshly
squeezed lime juice
delicious nice
lovely you can try to to break the main
joint here and
if you're lucky keep it whole
the meat will come out like this
lovely
it's the size of a lobster tail isn't it
now look at that that
smells and looks amazing
this
is what i've been waiting for
[Music]
beautiful
that's delicious
my god i actually now think i prefer
it's lobster
so much softer and sweeter
is there any more
or do i have to go back down and get
another one maybe you have to go down
with gary's help i shot three in around
three hours and they weren't going
anywhere